嘿，你猜不到今天看到一個什麼新聞，真的出乎意料，一家德國新創叫 Cloover，成立才三年，竟然就獲利了。
三年就獲利？這在AI新創圈裡，尤其是這種能源平台，怎麼說呢，感覺很少見。他們做什麼的？賣AI軟體嗎？
不是賣軟體那麼簡單。他們做的是住宅太陽能、熱泵跟家庭電氣化的整合，但最特別的是，他們是「AI原生新公用事業」。
AI原生新公用事業？這詞聽起來有點拗口。意思是他們從底層就用AI來設計服務，而不只是把AI當成優化工具？
對，就是這個意思。共同創辦人 Gönczy 就說了，他們做的一切都跑在AI上，從審核到每戶家庭的能源優化，現有廠商用AI都是在舊系統上加，他們卻能秒級處理，別人要花好幾天。
嗯，所以他們是透過AI來提升效率，降低成本，然後因此快速獲利？但三年內就達到年營收超過三億歐元，這數字是怎麼來的？
這點其實很有意思。他們不自己組銷售團隊，而是打造了一個AI原生的作業系統，供給獨立安裝商使用。
等等，這裡我有疑問。他們是把技術賣給安裝商，讓安裝商去接觸客戶？這樣利潤不會被分薄嗎？他們怎麼確保能快速擴張？
他們的模式是，安裝商保留自己的品牌跟客戶，然後販售太陽能、熱泵等產品，而融資方案是內嵌在銷售環節裡的。
融資方案內嵌？意思是消費者買的時候就能順便申請貸款，而且是Cloover提供融資？
對，Cloover提供融資、軟體和能源產品。客戶兩分鐘內就能拿到決定，不用預付任何費用，最長還能分期25年。這降低了消費者門檻。
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字，他們已經獲得了超過11.2億歐元的融資承諾，其中歐洲投資基金還提供3.5億歐元的擔保，這筆錢就是用來支持能源設備安裝的。
而且他們的共同創辦人 Betschart 也說，他們透過客戶已經信任的安裝商接觸家庭，然後把每個家庭變成一個發電廠，讓屋主參與到能源市場裡。
把每戶家庭變成發電廠，還能參與能源市場？這是指什麼？賣電給電網嗎？
他們現在的目標是把每個家變成一個虛擬發電廠。透過他們的居家能源管理系統，結合動態或固定費率，再把分散式太陽能、電池、熱泵、電動車充電器這些，整合成一個可交易的彈性電量池。
這就是他們說的「AI原生新公用事業」核心概念？就是不擁有自己的發電廠，而是把所有用戶的發電、儲能都整合起來，變成電網的資源？
對。他們解釋說，傳統的供應商是買電賣電，然後比價，但他們這種「新公用事業」不擁有任何發電設備，他們的能力來自於這個巨大的「已安裝基礎」，以及這些家庭能為電網帶來的價值。
難怪他們三年就能這麼快獲利，因為他們不是重資產模式，而是用AI跟金融工具去撬動現有安裝商網路和用戶。那對中小企業來說，能從中學到什麼？
我覺得，最重要的一點是，把AI從底層思維融入服務設計，不是拿AI來做錦上添花。想想看，如果今天你開餐廳，不只是用AI點餐、算庫存，而是AI來重新定義你的餐飲服務模式。
怎麼說呢？比如，AI根據每位顧客的飲食習慣、健康數據，推薦客製化菜單，甚至預測你的身體狀況，提前提供預防性的飲食方案？
嗯，有點像。而且 Cloover 證明了，AI不只可以優化，還能重塑產業，並且能快速變現。他們透過清晰的商業策略，把AI跟金融工具結合，快速實現了盈利和規模化。
對於一般上班族來說，這個概念也能應用嗎？
我覺得，這也提醒我們，工作上不該只把新工具當成輔助。也許可以試著跳脫現有框架，去思考如何用新技術「重塑」自己的工作流程或產出，而不是只停留在「優化」現有模式。
確實，以前我們覺得AI是幫忙做重複性工作，但他們這種「AI原生」的思維，是讓AI從頭定義工作本身。
沒錯。這種做法很有意思，也提醒了我們，在面對新的技術浪潮時，或許可以更勇敢地去想像和實踐不同的可能性。